live
[Music]
is being played right now Windows 11 OS
it's all yours thank you thank you
appreciate it so there's here we have it
the wrong Ally and this is still running
see if you want to play a different game
you can exit out of this we have a
number of others you can play just want
to make sure you're not home
that'd be great too here
[Music]
strawberry
device itself is
looking at the back thanks
[Music]
for Forza
of course
everybody
[Music]
over here
foreign
[Music]
okay so we have our basic UI game
Library set
good stuff
it's like this kind of a preset
FPS we don't check that out y'all looks
like these a lot for this demo version
right here so we'll be the best with
that too much
[Music]
screenshots
game profiles
FPS Eliminator got a refresh rate
resolutions basic M UI give me your
gallery for your screenshots the system
here we are right here and that Rising
about 500 gigs of storage
checking it out
it's really light that's the first thing
you're gonna Notice off the bat it's
really like comfortable d-pad feels very
responsive I have to get that off the
rep let's go back here that's what it is
always looks like we got our standard uh
right analog for our cursor and moving
around see if we can use see if we can
use it is it time oh okay yes we do we
have our touchscreen
standpoint
[Music]
machine
I just go back and
do anything on that okay here we go what
we want to do is see if we can equip
that because I don't want to have all
these things running
and I don't see where I can quit it but
it's all good
I'm figuring out on the Fly y'all
there's our power I guess it looks like
our volume knocker looks like SD card
right there headphone jack you know into
our HDMI display and again some
information
I'm
just gonna actually do a hard switch and
see what happens
[Music]
all right so that's all what happens
when we hit this aha here we go so we
get the prompt of the applications
running and it's recommended you close
so we are going to do that we want to
save resources we have closed Forza
Horizon four and now we're gonna see if
this Xbox at native
he's ready all right
if you have any questions let me know
and I believe I can get this screen out
of our way let's actually press this
button again there we go all right so
here we go we got our standard gear I'm
gonna see if it's negative or not I'm
not sure it's just um
okay all right all right see
theoretically we could have Xbox going
on right now
questions so I've noticed how many Xbox
app so is this all the streaming version
this is native because all the games
that are we have currently here are like
installed yes um if you want to do Cloud
games you can go there I don't know if
it's going to work um right I understand
because of the conditions but yeah and
the Wi-Fi in here as well I would
imagine so much but it does work with
card gaming here too yes the question I
had though is because this is a Windows
11 OS you know could you install Game
Pass natively like local yeah so it
should be so fortunate and high in life
those are coming from Gatehouse okay
um locally nice yeah you can sell any
game pass game on there just like you
would on a PC gotcha and again just from
a functionality I'm just trying to see
like one of these like going back to
like almost like a home button yeah so
so these are these two buttons here are
the same as they are on an Xbox
controller these are our buttons so this
brings up the control center which I
think we can change the operating mode
quick access to settings I mean that's
actually customizable and then this one
just takes you to Armory break which is
awesome settings and uh we'll detect all
of your assault games okay do I have
this game on Steam or is it on Gog
that's what this is all of your
installed games
when you start the device that's pretty
cool that is pretty cool
uh like the way it's made in one screen
is about a specific support
so you're hurting it first from the Reps
it looks like native functionality
um we do have you you know you can run
MSR on games and support it and it also
has rsr in the AMD driver so if you have
a game where
um you know you're getting good
performance at 1080p but you want to
bump the frame rate higher because it is
a 120 hertz display you can turn on rsr
in the driver where if like we'll render
it at 720 and scale it up
[Music]
is there some type of only I don't like
the deck the steam deck would have like
something that you can kind of see what
yeah yeah there's a there's an on-screen
overlay and uh
foreign
nice but it's really nice to have that
just like a shortcut away
so uh it depends on what you're doing so
for like you know super high gaming
where you're pushing the GPU to its Max
in your turbo mode you'll get like one
or two hours out of it
um but if you are playing like so when I
play dead cells on it I think it's like
three hours because it's a much less
to 60 and kind of stretch it out and if
you're doing like Netflix
tonight
Xbox top gaming you can get like three
or four plus hours out of it which is a
nice a nice alternative you have a good
network connection if you want to
stretch out which station
cool and of course that depends on race
so if you go to Center here as well
[Music]
right on the floor yes
right very cool there's a friend as a
county
yeah
yeah so those are the options and if you
want to Army great you've actually there
are a few options
you can customize that quick settings so
it's just like you would I'm like oh or
whatever yeah there you go like take
away ones you don't want or add other
ones kind of customize it to the
settings that you need quick access
you like change the lighting or have
access to your you can record uh
gameplay and have quick access to like
your library of recordings
um and share them to social media things
like that cool cool
now as far as that uh screenshot
functionality that you were saying
now as far as it like screenshotted like
taking the video functionality that you
were mentioning like so I don't remember
how to do it but here's a cool trick you
can hold this and it'll show you the
uh-huh okay gotcha and there should so
the the paddles on the back
to by default those are like modifiers
like hold one of those and press a I
think if you hold one of those Acres
like I actually remapped them to uh the
left bumper and right bumper so it's a
little bit easier to hit them with my
fingers oh wow
you can customize the key mapping to do
whatever you want or create your own
shortcuts with those buttons it looks
like a game bar Microsoft game bar
integration as well which is really cool
PC standpoint nice
oh that's anything happened to me
yeah
foreign
[Music]
like
pieces
um I don't I don't know I
like it's also different because like
you know a lot of games
the handheld device
low energy
yeah I was thinking like what would be
the laptop would be amazing
what was the movie good y'all
yeah definitely
yeah this is a showcase the fact that
it's native is so impressive
and because it's like it's like having
anti-aliasing that gives you more
important
doesn't have that function yeah that's
right that's right five does correct
correct but yeah so in a case like
you're like four turn on rsr and scale
it from 720p up I think I think that
probably doesn't look as good as native
1080p but it gets you a lot more
performance
and those those options
no no sorry FSR is a in game these
options should stay the same
it seems like you'd have a great
relationship with Microsoft as far as
the integration yeah
we've worked with my
oh wow nice
Big Game Pass and
kind of device shoot in addition to
planning the fact that it can play games
locally what just happened
no no I did I did I did a rewind yeah
when I make mistakes Forza has that
great ability
aspiring
[Music]
that's awesome
and it was like I made up
thank you see here you have it guys The
Rock Allied local Forza Horizon
480p
120 and it feels small
I will say the control feels really good
for games I'm very impressed with the
control and it's very lightweight y'all
I have to like you have no idea how it
really feels good
functionality
I wish I had more games demo for you
guys but of course I got to go to force
one of the showcases
all gameplay exclusive from the Lords
[Music]
the finish this race y'all bring it home
did it and there you have it
Vlog Ally Lords of gaming exclusive
this is it it's a beautiful body really
cool again it's a little warm but not
like steam deck warm I'll say that and
um again it's very Sleek very sleepy
guys
mess around looking at some more
settings
and on Bluetooth on Wi-Fi you got your
audio settings your lighting
it's really cool
[Music]
desktop mode
get your configuration on looks here's
our mappings
this is pretty awesome stuff
it pretty much couldn't figure out how
you want see how PCS
that
it's back up here
Armory crate okay we don't want to exit
just yet let's move back out look at the
content settings
and platform browsing download games aha
here we go and then if you have your
Xbox
installed local EA steam you got your
epic engine see this is the key this is
the difference but I feel it's a huge
advantage of the Ally the fact that you
can have these on you're not tired
you're not locked into Steam OS pretty
much pretty cool you gotta um Ubisoft
connect
[Music]
I like it
with the steam
it looks like we're at 1080 120 right
now
in that 119.
question right now
so ghost runner on Steam
see some settings
yeah
Fidelity FX up to here
high quality packs all that good stuff
controls I'm just gonna get into it just
just want to see functionality
yeah yeah
a frog Ally the Lord's playing it first
exclusive New York City in the building
it's so far y'all feeling it so far
I'm gonna play this actually it's gonna
be funny I'm a demo it jumped off so we
got a Type 4 like we're on the just
butchered we're gonna restart though
we're gonna act like we didn't see that
now this is where I'm noticing the
analogs are a little Twitchy
we're doing something wrong but whatever
we're just testing the functionality
right now tested before Oh we just got
slash I means that's what it is
hey okay now this is what I'm noticing
y'all see the analog you probably have
to do some configuration it's very
touchy but I'm assuming this is just a
setting in the game itself
as opposed to naming this is all and
using error because clearly I don't play
this
are we going to find out what our Crouch
is
left control all right
all right we ain't messing with this too
tough I just wanted to see this just
wanted to see a steam game to be honest
just to see it running it really looks
cool I know so like so I never played
kitchen my understanding is yeah
the breath of the wild MMO with vipers
now we have our clown yeah
so I've still never played yeah nice
Game Pass app interface
let's see some basic windows 11.
no one on the store
Library
[Music]
questions so let's just say we just want
to see basic Windows 11 Southwest first
of all I think you probably need to
quickly
running okay so let's quit the games I
would go into them oh well here you go
so you can drag up from the bottom again
what I would do is I would quit these
games first and yes Windows
oh oh sorry I missed it hold on exit to
desktop sorry I'm not used to the Forza
Horizon 4 uh interface 7.5 yeah same
quit a ghost Runner so then you can have
a swipe up from the bottom
got it okay got it
that's uh
there we go okay
okay so again you can just exit out of
this if you want and then so if you're
an army crate you just press this and
it'll minimize right then you can
thank you
foreign
y'all just checking things out on the
Fly seeing what's going on but yeah
fully functioned windows 11.
by the way
so you don't have to like typing oh
really
so think so fingerprint sensor so you
can just turn it on and log in right now
thank you
you guys also can't tell it's kind of a
crowded I just think it's quiet yeah I'm
like I was actually really really
impressive yeah
and I'm surprised he doesn't run super
hard I'm assuming like the fan
just because fans come out the back here
yeah
there we go
yeah that's good very cool very cool
yeah feel it man very impressed with the
rock alley thank you
[Music]
I'm so interesting don't trust him
and there you have it
[Music]